foreign
[Music]
show that keeps you updated on all the
nerdy news you need to know we're
thrilled to have you here today on this
Friday coming up the Guardians of the
Galaxy holiday special has some very
interesting updates we're excited to
talk about those and hey Thor says
witness me AKA he's trying to die oh man
um in holy smokes Indiana Jones five ah
why'd there have to be five uh that was
a snake's joke I got the snakes joke uh
with me to today to talk about those
topics and others we've got Jay
Washington I'm back yeah yeah
I have to be back this is gonna be fun
yes sir I've already heard what things
are happening
right next up we've got Jessica Clemens
I'm here for fun yes
yes Tommy Bechtel it's a business
decision for me to be here today
what you're thinking
[Applause]
but home Tag's still on see you next
week
she's the he's the Men in Black of
flannels it's just a closet this is my
look baby I got my Cuban links I got my
Kohl's super soft t-shirt Got My Adidas
headband not a plug for any of these
Brands I like let everyone know right
now as I look in the camera Tommy moves
away okay time you move away I just you
got to figure out what weight I'm
talking about I moved my weight from my
stomach to my ass that's what he's going
to say he's migrating all over the
streets in me knows difference Tommy's
changed
speaking of what uh we appreciate
everybody in the chat a couple folks
already throwing in some Super Chips
uh oh we we gotta close down for now but
um
we have a super chat Redemption we got a
hot Redemption today in FYI uh this is
our last uh break room before we're
taking next week off due to the holiday
week uh we won't be here next week we'll
come back right after Thanksgiving but
this is our last show before
Thanksgiving that's right and we are so
thankful that's what today's Redemption
is all about for every fifty dollars you
trash bag garbage tortillas give us we
have uh mystery shots of Thanksgiving
side dishes that's right shot glasses
and blue Dixie Cups because we ran out
of shot glasses full of Thanksgiving
Delights or defrights it doesn't who
knows it could be trash it could be
treasure whatever your pleasure and let
me say this we've got six shots of
Thanksgiving treats if we hit that 300
mark and raise all six shots
there's going to kick in a bonus
Redemption if we raise 200 more dollars
on top of that so 500 total I will do a
shot of De bomb sauce equal parts mixed
with gravy live on the air so you know
it's real I will ruin my weekend for you
tell me this is truly can you explain
briefly what de bomb sauce is sweat the
bomb sauce is from the show hot ones the
the popular online show hot ones uh it
is the I believe the second spiciest
sauce on their thing it used to be the
the number one the the gold standards
the classic but it but it is what it is
is basically on it has no taste it
simply has pain okay it is the
Hellraiser of sauces real quick Jesus
when we used to do blurs in the hood
winston-day Marshall and I did this we
did the hot wings Challenge and we got
to the bomb yeah and like you said it's
nothing but yeah it is Satan's sweat
yeah and and loot secretions it is
literally like Lucifer breathing in a
pepper it is well it's like you remember
those things when you were a kid and
you'd put your hands into the pins and
it would make the output of your hand on
the other side it's like doing that to
your nuts with real nails
how's that Bucky Barnes ATL uh Matthew
Nunya and Christian unpronounceable are
already putting you on the road to
hellsville oh God come on
but hey almost almost to the shots
almost to the shots I know
our first shot
as we await Our Fate there let's get to
some headlines
so good at math 21. wonderful
um this is also the last episode before
the release of the Guardians of the
Galaxy holiday special that's coming out
November 25th we're very excited for
that there has not been a lot of
promotion for it they dropped one little
low-key trailer that did tell us oh
Kevin Bacon's gonna be in it didn't give
us many other details they've not been
promoting it a lot we're very excited
for it though we got some new images
from the Set uh Dash will do it there oh
there's a little mantis looking cute and
festive she's so cute she's a
sweethearted person whoa
I guess he is okay good yeah Sean's
amazing and those two are openly racist
in person
no great and so oh no comment and Dave
I'm like this sodium level is way too
much natural can you go back to that
last photo just one more time
Chris Pratt looks like you just saw the
uh election results
the Los Angeles mayoral
elections okay
um so you know I'm here I have supported
again they don't they'll give us a ton
of details I love that all the
characters are wearing kind of festive
holiday gear this might probably have no
idea what any of it means yeah mostly
they're aliens
um and there was also a featurette
released today we're not gonna play that
right dashel okay we won't play that but
you could you could watch that um it
kind of gave a little behind the scenes
um look at the special presentation and
just before the show sorry to interrupt
they did also release on Twitter if you
want to see just an extended little
snippet of that opening scene between
Drax and mantis where they make the
decision to cheer Peter up so it's
basically the scene you get in the
trailer that's like roughly 15 seconds
it's 57 seconds of it so if you want to
see just a little more of that a little
more of why they make the decision it's
not necessarily I think essential
viewing but it's cute and if you like
mantis and Drax like I do treat yourself
to a minute break treat yourself that's
a feature right that came out no no that
was just a little tweet a little tweet
uh snippet you know they're getting them
out on Twitter while we can guys and we
will be doing on the channel Eric Voss
is going to do a breakdown of the little
feature at it should be coming out
Monday
um but there was some interesting news
kind of the press surrounding these
things has been really interesting
there's been some great quotes Kevin
feige said this was the very first thing
uh they conceived of for Marvel content
on Disney plus oh my God that's amazing
the four one division yeah four Loki
before Hawkeyes
look at who are we talking about though
we're talking about James Gunn yeah
we're talking about a dude whose mind is
just spewing out ideas that when they
spew or dispute they work and he's so
he's so eccentric in the right ways
where like I'm sure he thought when I
was a kid the Star Wars holiday special
absolutely devastated me like it did
everyone else and I will spend the rest
of my life try oh sorry baby
coach uh uh I'm sure he's like I'm going
to make a holiday special for a popular
space franchise someday he just seems
like the type of person that has had
that like written like Marvel holiday
special has been written in a notebook
for him since like 1995. it's not our
first holiday special Marvels right it
is
like Deadpool had like a holiday special
too or was it uh when he did like
Christmas The Princess Bride Edition
um
video that he put out was that dead I
thought it went to theaters and it was
like specifically called like no they
did the PG-13 that was The Princess
Bride version yeah
all right so but this is a Marvel's
first like yes well and certainly the
first thing on Disney plus yes which is
interesting that like over almost two
years into Disney plus yeah they were
like you know what we want
um and and again this is just the second
special presentation after werewolf by
night yes which was a home run yes
though even think about the different
scale here werewolf by night was great
but it's like that was a modestly budget
thing Gabriel Garcia Bernal great actor
but like no movie stars in that I mean
this is like the full cast of Guardians
but it was perfect timing because he
filmed this while filming Guardians
three yeah so he didn't have to he
didn't have to pull people back and
everything so he already had them
available so it was the perfect time to
film and shoot everything which works
you just add a little holiday
festivities into into the set I I hear
that and I also think the titling is
important to remember here it is the
Guardians of the Galaxy holiday special
which is a direct mirror of the Star
Wars holiday special which famously
featured two characters from Star Wars
the movies that we loved and just very
tiny cameos from everyone else Mark
Hamill's in it for like three minutes
Carrie Fisher's in it for like B Arthur
from The Golden Girls yeah hosts Harvey
Corman an hour
and that's in a little thing called
bootleg breakdowns look it up on our
YouTube channel I did break it down I I
watched it so you guys didn't well and
but it's interesting in that that was
also that was a weird like variety show
that they tried to capitalize on the
popularity of Star Wars this is not this
feels like uh a one-act play or just
like a little chunk of a movie before a
big movie is this just gonna be I think
it's we don't know enough to know is
this just a fun little side quest where
they're like give us a couple million
bucks and we'll make uh 25 minutes of
extra Guardian stuff or is this like
this is the setup for what's gonna be
the final fantas yeah he didn't yeah no
you go I don't know I think he said
there that's all I was gonna say was I
think he said it is this goes into three
well it was all via Twitter as we know
James gotten is the master of the tweets
that you maybe take seriously or you
maybe take worth a grain of salt and he
never he's very unpredictable
I'm trying to be if you are doing a
princess Wildcats and here you go there
you go oh I heard it I think first of
all he'd be a fool not to hire you yes
and uh and I'll put that on or not to
come on the show yeah come on the show
you guys but also the tweets were that
this is the Epic he called it the not a
he called it this is the epilogue to
phase four wait was he talking about the
holiday special or was he talking about
Guardians holiday special which makes
sense and he also said and and uh Palm
clementov reiterated in her interview
that there are elements from this
holiday special that you need to know
before you see Guardians of the Galaxy
3. so this ain't one of those if you hit
it on the DVR and save it for later baby
you need to watch this the only thing I
don't like about that statement is he
was like
oh after wakanda forever oh you have to
watch my movie because he's like it's
the epilogue this is like an ice boards
because like Marvel said that what kind
of forever was the end yeah is the phase
four he's like oh my thing's also coming
out right after that I guess it's the
epilogue I guess James James was like yo
this is the post credit scene yeah
so he's pretty good at trying to he he
has to it's like the same thing with the
Groot series it's like yeah I need you
you guys need to watch all of it yeah
the way he you know he's he's I mean
almost more than any other Marvel
director he's leaned into the Easter egg
that's right especially with his like
there's one Easter egg no one can ever
get uh empty still out there scouring
yeah
I think Mt has got it and he's just like
oh [ __ ] I can't I actually think he
might be waiting till after Guardians
again
he's also James is just holding out
because he knows like there's one house
in Massachusetts that just has Guardians
Anaconda
we've got a couple other little details
about the holiday special written in
three days I don't know if that's a good
thing or a bad thing but whatever it's
right I mean it's James good again he's
prolific you know what I mean Peacemaker
yes yeah every episode well and speaking
of Peacemaker this is an original song
in it of course the Guardians movie is
known for their great soundtracks
um but he wrote an original song for
this movie which he did a bunch of
original songs for a piece I believe
that the title song in Peacemaker which
sounds like a classic rock song is
actually just a song from manure it's
just done in that it's not wig at all
yeah what's that it's not Wigwam it's
just some other group yeah okay cool
cool uh and then Bob clementov clementif
uh Clements Clementine uh of course the
actress who portrays mantis uh said the
movie is gonna have a big reveal
she said yes there's a big reveal that
you need to watch now of course you
can't fall to any actor or director for
saying you need to watch this right of
course I want people to watch it uh and
then James Gunn and a reply to someone
calling the special a must watch said
absolutely there's a lot of big
information yes this is basically what I
was uh saying earlier in a much more
official capacity however we're all a
little snake bit after Vision or after
Paul Bettany said that he got to act
alongside an accident he always dreamed
a vacuum
Gleason I thought it was so funny I was
like he got me
I think it was just more more hurtful to
us because it's our job to like you know
cover that stuff and we're like who are
we gonna do a video about and it's like
oh just the two of them by the way we're
very close to two side shots so and I do
one at a time we'll get those here give
me a moment thank you for everybody in
the Super Chat including trash bag uh
proud 81 Mama GSU Eagle a bunch of other
folks thank you
um coming back to what James Gunn said
about the holiday special he said it's
in Canon it's about the Guardians you're
gonna learn stuff that you need to learn
before volume three and it's great well
that that should go without saying and
I'm really happy with it um
yeah she's like it's man you should
watch it uh it's kind of mid of course
it's great as everything that they've
made with the Guardians in it has been a
lot of fun and great
um I think it's interesting you know
it's got a lot of important stuff and
you're gonna learn stuff he's saying
yeah like you know so often when a movie
movie and a franchise starts oh some
stuff has happened off camera in between
the last time we saw those people right
I like like well or you could just show
us what happened in between you know
what I mean like catch us up so that
Guardian Street can start and hit the
ground running but for people like us
the fans the completionists will will
want to know that like a little bit of
backstory that like gets cut out from
the beginning of the movie right I like
if if that's what happens in this
episode really cool we probably find out
why Drax has never heard of Christmas
but it was called something else and he
used to celebrate it we called it
Slaughter day
Saturday Night Live there's just Buckets
of Blood Out Here we had a dead pig
skeleton you topped a needle tree with a
separate head of your entity I love that
I want to see it yeah Mary Slaughter day
everyone
and of course yeah as Tommy pointed out
they filmed it simultaneously with
guardians 3 so it's coming out or Jay
pointed that out thank you it's coming
out at the good job end of next year I
believe that's coming out or not the end
it's coming out in July of 2023 so not
that far off so this is coming the
holiday special comes out next week yes
and then the movie movie comes out in
July July not that far out that's far
that's so much and I mean think about it
we just got the Guardians a little bit
just a tiny bit and throw love and
thunder yeah that's three appearances in
12 months oh that's kind of nice do we
know if uh the holiday special is
anywhere around Thor love and thunder or
do you think those holiday special throw
love and thunder then Guardians of the
Galaxy remember Kobe messed everything
up as far as the timeline goes we just
do the holiday special was where it is
that's it like you know what I'm saying
like Guardians 3 yes it's behind but
could it be you know things have moved
around
did debunk a fan rumor that was going
around that Silver Surfer was going to
appear in this oh wait wait wait why
I could get up here
previously owned by Fox has appeared in
that it does before movie which that is
just kind of more recently come over to
the MCU and so we think he's gonna show
up at some point Guardians are in space
silver surface in space maybe that's why
people are pushing that what if he's
just referenced like we don't see him
like there's a Herald walking they're
flying around on the surfboard or
something like that well don't you think
and I know that they're completely
different but if we get Silver Surfer
and then we're getting uh what's his
name in Guardians of Galaxy
yeah it's like you got two sharp fast
Space men just rolling around each other
and the high evolutionary some black
some black dude that's in power that
really a lot of people don't like
January 6. but like it's just a whole
bunch of things that happen I don't know
I just know I'm not saying he was oh I
was like I don't know I was like
Wow that'd be crazy but no like maybe we
get the introduction or you know tidbits
about the high evolutionary because we
already know where Adam's coming from we
know he's coming from the gold people
yeah you know right
so maybe something about where the high
evolutionary Rockets backstory starts to
come into play with the otter yes yes
yeah yeah they have a lot to set up that
we know is going to appear in Guardians
3 so maybe they start setting up some of
that now God damn I'm sorry all right we
got a super chat for a hundred dollars
happy Friday
well I guess that there's no poll where
all four of us are doing it it's
basically it's basically a full meal at
this point again tell me how far away
are we from you uh ruining your own life
uh well that would be we're three
hundred dollars away oh my God never
mind we're actually 93 103. no
1995
all right so oh this is real here's what
we have this is a mashed sweet potato
okay a cranberry this is the Alfredo
pumpkin and this is pure gravy okay I'll
do I'll do pure gravy for the team
unless you'd rather I don't know I
already think I have some gravy coming
my way a little bit later
automatically appropriate I've got B
Arthur on mine I got Sophia I got the
hot thought Blanche from this and I've
got Betty White ironic recipe
I like to say before I do this shot this
is probably gonna be not safe for work
are you ready Oh Happy Thanksgiving
everybody Happy Thanksgiving everybody
I can't eat mine after what I just saw
Jay do this someone called the police on
Jay why did someone call the police put
him in prison after what I just
witnessed I'm gonna call HR immediately
after this oh my God he's like Gene
Simmons with that thing for God Jay's
got himself a top piece how did this
video just get demonetized
to see this video as a scene of
sensuality a man a man gave great
pleasure to run a hand from behind the
grave
how appropriate for room though
um uh you guys would have wanted to be
eating like that
thank you to the real tree you could
create uh Bucky Barn Vera Morris Jeremy
Lee everybody oh hey
I've been I have been mispronouncing it
it's Jamie Riley Jamie Riley okay
correcting but the name is j-ride mealy
so I don't really know how we need to be
corrected on that I think that the name
got scrambled oh I think he like mixes
and matches it's an anagram this is like
the da Vinci um well thank you to that
and uh strange it's uh gravy is not
meant to be consumed by itself no yeah I
will say the Alfredo sauce uh should be
afraid though of being put on anything
it's terrible I like the cranberry sauce
but I think I got the easiest sweet
potatoes right yeah you assaulted it
her pleasure to it we don't know
um so Mark Hamill did uh he replied to a
James Gunn tweet with a a snarky little
quote saying I have a very bad feeling
about this to a tweet about the holiday
special now this could just be an inside
joke because again he was in the
original Star Wars holiday special so
he's kind of doing a wink wink but some
fans are speculating he might cameo in
it possibly a Santa we know Kevin
Bacon's getting his way in there that's
true he's in the trailer maybe there's
some other 80s icons Luke Skywalker
because he's Star Wars oh he's just
dressed wait wait wait wait just
randomly what do you do what if it's
Mark Hamill just dressed as Luke
Skywalker look in the R2 unit as long as
we get there
ever since they bought uh you know
marvel was bought by Disney there's a
lot of Star Wars stuff throughout the
MCU right like Peter Parker has the
Death Star or Lego and uh by the way why
is Jay shot glass smoking a cigarette
right now
I said the holiday special will
introduce one of the greatest MCU
characters of all time now this is
almost certainly a joke yeah right
it's gonna be like a Howard the Duck
type look James good loves Bat Bike more
than anything else in DC so you gotta
think which obscure Marvel character
could he be talking about yeah because
he's not talking about anybody we want
to really see is it like a live-action
spider pig
he's already in across the area
they probably don't have rights oh sure
sure what okay but I mean MCU makes you
think oh man Mojo maybe Mojo
[Laughter]
speaking of
um [ __ ] turns the show could take
um we've been having a great week with
our sponsor ink box again inkbox makes
these very fancy nice uh temporary
tattoos uh you can design your own on
their website whatever you want to make
a temporary tattoo out of you can you
can put it in their little custom
designer and then it'll spit they'll
mail it to you last two two weeks you
get them for your friends whatever uh
we've been they've got thousands of
designs on there we've been doing a
little contest Monday through Wednesday
we did a contest to see between Tommy
and I who would get a design the other
guy made I won and yesterday on this
show at the end of the show I put in the
[ __ ] Stamp position a Gucci tumuchi
tattoo I'm gonna reveal it now they take
about 24 hours
um
so this is
go back in front of the remote
and there you go there you go oh my God
now it's still kind of darkening stay
there oh that's good there you got it
you got it
in Focus it's still pretty blue but
probably another like four or five hours
it'll be like nice and dark and black
now because we
um got over 300 in super chats yesterday
Tommy agreed to also get my design on
himself
first things wait do you have your mic
your mic
oh wait you can't show nipples can you
hide them
first thing okay first thing uh the new
rockstars one didn't work oh okay
but guess what did work it's morbid time
now again it's it's a it's morbid time
okay it's really dark there but if you
go back okay oh my god there you go stay
there
look that's a little clock and then it
says it's morbid time now Tommy just put
his on so it's gonna darken over time
and it'll be just in time for
Thanksgiving holiday it'll be nice and
black can we talk we showed off to all
his family
um and then I I think I mentioned
yesterday I got this one about 18 days
ago a little bit over two weeks
something like that let's kind of you
know just lightly fading probably in
three or four more days it'll be totally
gone just but I like that I don't know
if you've ever had those cheap uh
temporary tattoos in your little kid and
they get all like patchy and they kind
of flake off and they don't look that
great I like that this guy just kind of
slowly Fades into the distance
um Zach can we ask why you yours makes
you look like a bad [ __ ]
I'm trying to think of the funniest
place to put it and uh it was not
appropriate for the camera and so uh
that's why I made it into my lower back
and I mean can I mention Zach because I
want to thank box personally I was
seeing this girl named Gina she was
really pressuring me to get her name
tattooed on my body so I ain't boxed it
we broke up and now I'm seeing a girl
named Sandra I just put a fresh Sandra
tattoo on I can keep this up with my
hustle with my ladies especially if you
date these women about two weeks apart
Tommy and that's what I always have free
landscape I call it my fortnite games
okay and it's not uh like a skin that
you bought in the game oh there's skin
all right uh but hey they're getting by
for sponsoring all this silliness all
week to get your owning box tattoos
check out all their designs they've got
some cool IP collaborations fun artistic
stuff all kinds of a wide variety of
styles click the link in the video
description or head to inkbox.com and
use our promo codes they know we sent
you new rockstars get 25 off your entire
inbox order that code is good to the end
of the year but you can only use it once
so go and buy a bunch give something to
friends again I I think like if you're
playing on a trip or you want to do a
silly thing for your family get them all
the same yeah a temporary tattoo get
Grandma Inked Up Just for a couple weeks
get an F Mickey tattoo if you're going
to Universal you know really let them
know
and such a specific thing Tommy
um okay back to other headlines thank
you Jessica Jessica
great job way better than dashel well
Joshua's uh preoccupied today we're down
a man here in the studio but um so uh
our other big topic Chris Hemsworth Thor
himself did an interview
um any he said specifically he wants to
close the book on Thor in the next film
oh my God close the book close the book
I mean
yeah he's already done the most so
oh
[Music]
yeah
um
so you're up here without Thor welcome
to Valhalla hello
let me show you my let me show you my
meal Noah
you want to cross this rainbow bridge
I'm going to show you the bifrost right
okay all right Jessica's not into this
you're not into this no uh what I was
gonna say was I before we were talking
about the headline before the shoot we
were saying that like yeah I mean uh
Chris Evans got his Farewell and then we
have Tony Stark getting his Farewell
everyone's kind of leaving and exiting
and with that comes like a lot of sorrow
but it's just like oh goodbye it's a
hearty goodbye he is still here and he's
probably like I want a hearty goodbye
yeah like a formal like yeah you get to
kind of take your hat off and hang it up
and like everybody says Ah we love you a
story right like all that adulation even
um uh Natasha also kind of got an out
right yeah you know Falcon winner and I
[ __ ] Hawkeye was basically just like
an all completely talked about it was a
certain it was her farewell yeah even
though she didn't get a funeral yeah
um exactly said this if he he's one of
The Originals like we said he's put his
timing if this man wants to go and do
more uh extraction and spider head
movies on Netflix let him absolutely
we're just surfing Australia
with this beautiful family or whatever
too yeah well and you know he's been
doing this character for 11 years now
presumably if they did a fifth film it's
not slated next year or the year after
or even the year after that maybe they
could squeeze it into phase six sometime
right maybe we're talking 20 26 2027 but
like so he will have been this character
for 15 years he deserves a swan that's
also a long time to stay ripped as
somebody who's never been ripped uh that
feels like a long time he's got his gym
though whatever it's called like zero
club or whatever but
I gotta say just a Thor aside go back
and watch Thor one and how different
he's so small he's such a little sweet
baby face he doesn't have his like his
stubble is like white peach fuzz it's so
funny like look yeah he's like he looks
like he's lit like a Barbara Walters
special like it's all Vaseline and like
he's so like well some real unusual wig
work in that movie too that has not aged
well yeah
um but I think like I unlike Iron Man
one hits and we're all like oh [ __ ] Iron
Man's great right like Thor Thor was
kind of different it took us each movie
okay oh Ragnarok whoa here's a new take
on this character right like and now we
spent so much time with this like with
this character I feel like we're all
like invested in it yeah um but he said
I feel like we'd probably have to close
the book If I ever did it again I feel
like it probably warrants that I feel
like it'd probably be the finale but
that's not based on anything anyone's
told me or any sort of plans this is not
Kevin feige being like I love that he
said to retire you know or anything like
that look at that Chris Hemsworth's
extortion died
Okay click it uh well and maybe some of
that is like again he wants that nice
dramatic send-off right yeah even he
just got to see Natalie Portman get that
in his own movies also to kill him as
soon as he gets a daughter is kind of
aggressive but do you kill him with Loki
and then the child just goes and gets
raised by either the guardians or
somebody else
or somebody like that yeah Valkyrie
takes the child
and then you have you kill off Hemsworth
and Hiddleston and then you have
Sylvia's your Loki oh I think yeah
that's a great point it's also going to
be no Loki in this last storm
the first the first Thor movie that
didn't have Loki in it we know we're
getting Loki season two next year that's
also not too far off yeah um how nice if
like these two characters have been so
linked this entire time like you've kind
of gone apart and then yeah they come
back together maybe the final history
and the final Hemsworth together right
be him like an actual grown not trying
to trick people he's like I fell in love
with myself and they play Gary Clark
Juniors come together
[Music]
work then it works and then they go the
new Loki is Sylvie
[Applause]
Valkyrie
raise me shout out Steve Winwood I know
you love the show come on the show come
on
come on
bring Michael McDonald with you we'll do
a full Yacht Rock episode
you don't know me but I'm Yours
oh my God you're saying D'Angelo earlier
this week
yeah yeah yeah that was me still still
one of me top five all-time music maybe
we'll do some Maximum later oh whoa Tony
Tony Tone maybe who knows how deep will
go
um we're less than 30 days away from the
Indiana Jones five trailer freaking wait
they've announced when the trip is going
to come out uh at about 28 days I
believe from today uh we don't know
eight days later yes roughly
um uh but in the meantime we did get our
first look at the film
um now Tommy you were at
d23 I sure was and they showed do they
show footage or images they basically
showed
I mean it wasn't presented as a trailer
it was presented as like a look a sneak
peek but it was cut like a trailer and
it was awesome and it looks really good
and it doesn't like hide the fact it's
not like the Irishman where you have
like De Niro like but they do have some
de-aging in it like he does flash back
to some old Indie Adventures well I
think that's his current age that's
de-aged I feel bad for that but I but I
think um uh uh I think it basically
showed this movie is going to be kind of
him looking back at his life a little
bit and then uh what's her name Phoebe
uh Bridges is her scenes looked
incredible in it it looked it felt like
an Indiana Jones movie it seems like
they all agree James Mangold was such a
fan of these movies he knew how to make
he knew how to step in for Steven
Spielberg uh James roller Bridge right
from from fleabag okay yeah I didn't
know if it was freebie Bridges the
singer
yeah get her in there too hoop earring
this time
my friend is working with Harrison Ford
right now and he said that he stood up
from his chair and uh was in like the
auto visible pain because he of of his
various injuries and he goes oh Brian
don't ever and he thought he was gonna
say get old and he said crash a plane
didn't talk to my friend Brian caught a
while sorry for stealing your story but
it was too funny not to share yeah
um uh what were you just saying uh I
mean he's been this character talk about
people who've been in characters for a
long time and also James Mangold
famously gave us a great outro for
another character we love Logan right
like that guy knows how to tell a great
kind of exit story I didn't realize
James Mangold directed Kate and Leopold
which is a Hugh Jackman movie he's a
really weird filmography like he goes
from Kate Leopold with you Jackman like
years later he's like right now you're
the wolf
um yeah we're really excited sorry Josh
did we have other images from there oh
look at him one right it's like very
artistic people listening on the podcast
right now oh don't describe it then oh
it's beautiful the color somebody called
him zaddy for some reason it's called
Indiana Jones Addie yeah you've not seen
the internet have you I don't know what
his name is turn it off Hey listen all
you simps you mid weirdos
your cringe okay uh yeah so we're
excited about that next year just real
quick we're kind of planning our 2023
both for the break room and new
rockstars in general a lot of cool stuff
coming out we'll be doing in December
we'll be doing some kind of both
recapping 2022 and projecting 2023 but
just the big sequels we're getting next
year Indiana Jones five fast ten oh my
God Mission Impossible seven four uh not
Barbie one of course uh none two
Insidious five oh my God a lot there's a
lot coming out next year and uh you know
my dad and mom have committed to taking
more home videos of me while I'm home so
there'll be a couple Bechtel sequels as
well first time on a jet ski we'll
hopefully capture that I'm hoping to get
up on water skis this summer 2023 is the
Year
Tommy okay uh real quick speaking of uh
jet skis and things we enjoy Outdoors
hey when it comes to climate action your
money is power with aspiration a new
kind of change is in your pocket simply
by moving your money to aspiration
you're giving your deposits a cleaner in
your home thank you to aspiration for
sponsoring the show all week long uh
they're a climate friendly alternative
for your money they let they actually
it's a card it made a tree every time
you swipe that card get Taco Bell boom
plant a tree uh go to REI buy yourself a
sleeping bag uh so you're gonna because
you're gonna go out with the Bechtel
family into the the woods of Northern uh
New York oh you don't want to do that
with us I got a couple brothers that
don't know how to control themselves at
night what does that mean
okay they do a lot of tickling and
coffee dumps where they pour hot coffee
on you pranks like that that's like a
coffee coffee dumps means something else
to me sticking a screwdriver into your
back and telling you it's a gun that's
no gun those aren't pillows all right
okay uh you know what they've they've uh
they've already planted 100 million
trees trees they're committed to
planting a billion trees by 2030. uh
best of all it's an easy card to get you
don't need a credit check there's no
overdraft fees it's a good service even
besides the great environmental benefits
uh and you can pay whatever you think is
fair even if that's zero because money
shouldn't stand in the way of you doing
the right thing help save the planet
with your aspiration debit card open
your account at aspiration.com tree
today that's easy to remember tree tree
aspiration.com tree just think what is
Groot
a tree uh do I do here
terms and conditions apply aspiration is
not a bank deposits are FDI and FDIC
insured up to two million dollars per
deposit Jay can I answer any questions
for you before I go into this next ad
read about the Bechtel Brothers Woods
trip coffee dumps hot coffee pranks
were you adopted
no no no
they can't be trusted but they never
hurt you listen to me I've been
reminding you for weeks now weeks to
check out the second season of the hit
show DC's Batman the audio Adventures
which is out now in HBO Max an
incredible cast including Rosario Dawson
childhood Crush of mine childhood what
am I talking about adulthood in love
with her still John Leguizamo never had
feelings for him but like his comedy
attracted to him
let me do this the way the teens like it
Bobby Moynihan smash Chris Parnell pass
Seth Meyer smash smash Jeffrey Wright
smash as the Batman himself this is an
incredible show full of crime humor and
Batman lore you guys you gotta listen
this is why it's so fun to listen to
things if you're like me you're a little
hyperactive you gotta calm down the way
this is presented is so digestible and
you catch things you focus it's kind of
like you know for me it's a little like
meditation to listen to this as a
podcast because I am learning it's funny
I'm hearing things that are familiar it
gets me to go look up supplementary like
oh what is that a reference to it's so
fun the whole season is already
available on uh to stream and season two
is out now on HBO Max like I said if you
love SNL and you love Batman if you're
like me this is where it meets it's
funny but it's also action-packed stream
DC's Batman the audio Adventure season
two on HBO Max
now it's time for mandatory fun whoa
no graphic okay mandatory fun no no it's
Christmas time and here we go Christmas
time it's time to snow in Buffalo stay
safe Buffalo five feet of snow the
football games in Detroit now uh
I did for what to eat another Christmas
snack yeah that's fine it's a
Thanksgiving treat Christmas we'll have
our uh our our handsome uh well Dash was
gonna bring it on over and I'll do that
uh but it's mandatory fun this is the
segment what is this one oh it's a full
Dixie cup what's the corn plants corn
wait what the smell shot of corn can I
see
let me go to the let me go to the
close-up give me a second no we don't
need to do that look at it oh this is
like a creamy type of corn this is not
like uh
oh my god do you do straight up there's
a there's a lot there's like a half a
can in that cup oh you know what I'm
outside of corn it was good I
like I said hey
take your corn it's Thanksgiving take
your corn and even though I give you
guys a hard time I am thankful for the
people that watch the show every day
I knew you wouldn't have you'd be
financially impotent you wouldn't be
able to get the 500 as I predicted
for the people like you that have to
scrape together to get out of your
garbage pails just to get a Taco Bell
bean and cheese burrito you can't even
afford Taco Bell hose meat okay emphasis
on hoes now thank you to ASC uh film
juice fix the Meat House and everybody I
was thinking contributed to the super
chats Coco mihos all right anyway I'm
taking that mouth shut it smells really
good I genuinely like it it's eating at
all it's like gravy corn
no
for many
Thanksgiving marks the beginning of
Christmas season put up the tree hang up
the lights
bust out the uh my form but for Santa
Claus it starts judgment month a brutal
month of him being the judge jury and
executioner of the children
maybe he doesn't do that
that's all it's all when he decides if
you've been naughty or nice now Santa
can't be here so he sent one of his
leaders to be here to cross-examine you
guys as you claim why you belong on the
nice list now I also have to go here's
what's crazy you guys know we're off
next weekend so I had to talk to Dr
nasty about Russian a surgical job he's
going to put a whooping crane spleen
into my body ASAP it's not the first
queen
I believe it
Tommy's had a baboon spleen at one point
in time uh yeah they had to take that
out I don't watch I don't want to know
again let's uh I think I'm in a whooping
crane oh uh a couple folks in the Super
Chat GSU Eagle will they bring in BRB to
pick up stormbreak Beta Ray Bill oh good
we were hoping we were getting him in
Thorn 11 Thunder yeah and then it was in
even like he's teased in Ragnarok if you
look on the side so it's like it's been
that's what everybody thought Christian
Bale was at first ladies and gentlemen
of the jury what the [ __ ]
I stand before you looking at three ho
ho goddess
I stand before you're looking at three
Scoundrels claiming their innocence they
belong on the nice list but I'll be the
judge of that Mr Zach Huddleston oh okay
I want to swear you in please raise your
right hand
face me oh okay oh all right what
that's how the justice system works in
the North Pole it's slapped first ask
question second now whoa okay
why do you belong on the nice list Zach
ooh Why do I belong on the nice list in
2022.
um you know what I'd like to think I was
an okay guy this year I uh uh I did I
had a busy year we I did uh my family
welcomed our first child okay
I guess that doesn't mean much about me
right I mean the child is thriving
that's it and you know they always say
uh this would be my first experience
having a kid on Christmas and they say
like you experience the holidays
differently went through the eyes of a
of a child or whatever you know as
opposed to being an adult or whatever um
I've still yet to say anything good I
did this year uh really all of that was
my wife
um you know what you know what I did do
um I uh yeah I guess not that hard you
did a lot of good things oh Tommy and I
were just sharing stories before the
show started there was a guy that was
being a real dick head too Monday night
and
um I didn't hit him I don't know
permission to treat the witness is
hostile okay fine I can never think of
good job of you out of the bathroom a
few times as I've gone in I've noticed
the paper towels have not been replaced
are you ready to admit in front of this
court that you occasionally do not
restock the paper supplies in the
bathroom that is true okay I I have
operational a bit of operation no
facilities duties here around the new
Rockstar's office and I'm not the best
sometimes I do miss out on some of those
okay that is naughty of me permission to
approach the bench permission granted
yeah could you also not provide me with
a free of charge Helix mattress this
year that's true I did hook you up with
a free mattress okay I rest my case on
Zach Huddleston Jay Washington
been nice this year Jay
depends on what your definition of nice
tell me at this court and this
years they're not they're way worse than
you why you deserve to be on the nice
list
um I I I made sure my son had a good
graduation on everything okay my
daughter got her costumes and everything
things that their parents thought that
their mama's daughter if they were gonna
do I did also uh I bought a memory foam
mattress and gave one woman great head
back in like March so I felt like that
should hold me over to at least December
like you saw my tongue did with the
sweet potatoes it was in Jesus God I
imagine she's still there right now what
Jay yes uh permission to treat the
witness's hospital permission what are
you asking permission uh myself
Jay
you're a professional wrestler I am do
you wrestle as a baby face
no because I don't like them you wrestle
as a heel have you cheated to win any
matches this year Jay
first of all I'm what's called a tweener
tweener not the other word a tweener
meaning no please
okay I can be uh face and heal at the
same time but I have not cheated I've
just used a lot of brute strength not
shrimp strong strong so with a U and F
strong strength yeah that's new to me
all right wow I rest my case
Jessica Clemens yes
yes apple of my eye sweet as pie cross
my heart and hope to live forever okay
have you been nice this year
and tell us why
um I've been known as the break rooms
Angel
um that's a fact I
um very nice
and I bring people coffee all the time
okay that is water let me ask you a
counter question
yeah
mm-hmm
we've gone out socially with our friend
Erica wusu to the player one arcade in
beautiful Vancouver
played the claw game there yes
never forced your friends to play the
claw game for hours at their own
Financial okay
well they beg you to let them stop so
they can feed their family
I'm team Michael else told can I see
Michael may I speak Mr elf told oh
Squire elves Squire sir Papa
um so there is tape there is physical
evidence from Erica wusu of you playing
the claw machine unprompted or Tommy
bech told plain unprofited I'm not
allowed in arcades elves must remain 50
feet from all our cases our magic is
powerless there and no one told you to
go play it YouTube or Tommy Beck told to
play it he chose to and he brings me the
prizes I never ask for them I'm confused
right now I'm did you say Vancouver
I didn't want to give the location oh
okay okay
I was camouflaging our location now
in front of I couldn't get it I couldn't
get Beyonce in front of our Lord and
savior Santa Claus this jury of trash
humans and you all I've made my
decisions oh okay his eyes are so cold
Jay
this stocking has a j on it and in it
you will find my decision please reveal
to the camera now what is this
box of tic tacs but what does it say on
it Naughty or Nice candy cane it says
nice it's nice if it's nice yes you'll
notice it's specifically the nice candy
oh okay very nice huh these days
okay okay
Zachary Huddleston Zachariah Huddleston
that's this that's the correct thing
they didn't have Z stockings at the CVS
but they did have an eight oh okay your
decision is inside your stocking oh okay
it also appears to be Tic Tacs let's see
nice okay congratulations you've made
the nice list and therefore we'll be
receiving a present from Santa Claus as
will you Jay we found your efforts in
the oral Department inspiring I'm
talking about the nice things he said
over the years yes Zach you're a
wonderful father and an even better
friend thank you Jessica Clemens I swear
to God said Ray
stocking at the CVS as well no I'm
worried about this rule of Threes oh no
Jessica what's in yours
nothing but cold cold
that's right and what else Jessica tiny
little rabbit I don't even want to look
at it those are Sour Patch Kids shaped
like coal Eric I don't know what they do
oh you got the naughty Tic Tacs now is
Jessica naughty or is it just wishful
thinking on my part guys only Christmas
will tell that's it I am T Michael elf
told and this is Ben Naughty or Nice
core thank you T Michael wow and thank
you everybody uh who oh we did do a poll
who is an audience you know what oh
who's the nicest oh Tommy won the
naughtiest by Atlanta and Jessica's the
Jessica one the nicest violence with
Tommy coming in last in the the nicest
category judging by the Brazzers video
Jay did with that shot glass earlier I
think he's probably the naughtiest
shot glass tight ass
oh my God
Boogie's World saying rip to y'all's
stomach LOL well so far I'm doing okay
we'll see what we'll see what's going on
that corn kind of set me off oh yeah
what'd you do before the corn it was the
I did the Alfredo pumpkin alfredo well
um uh uh Jamie Riley uh I totally did
riddle it personally I'm complicated and
I spread my wealth and hey we appreciate
that for you Jamie Riley we appreciate
everybody in the uh super chat today and
you know what I think I think we're
gonna go ahead and wrap it up we hope
again this is our last episode before
Thanksgiving Canada thanks for one of
the super chats oh yes please
um yeah it's been a minute
what a what a curveball
[Applause]
thank you everyone for watching uh all
up until this Thanksgiving I hope
everyone has a very merry Thanksgiving
if you are in Buffalo getting hit by
thunder snow a real thing Google yes it
is please be safe yes please be safe in
Western New York and everywhere else
getting hit by extreme weather elements
this year we love you and we need you
back out here God knows I can't do it
without the trash guys like like the uh
like the Mr Fusion Delorean from Back to
the Future too I run on trash
they fuel us uh and also real quick ASC
in the super chats you work for Vivint
the camera company uh featured in the
Guardians uh trailer we know and
actually we might be doing something
with your company sometime soon as see
uh but uh much appreciation to everybody
who watched and who watched all week uh
come back not next week but the week
after we're gonna have a lot of great
stuff we'll be reacting to this uh
Guardians film that will be out by that
point uh we appreciate you we've got
some local news there's a little
headline underneath
perhaps an appearance thank you for
reminding me and then the week after
that uh December 3rd yes right uh fourth
thank you Sunday December 4th we'll be
doing a live and in-person break room
show at La Comic-Con yes if you're going
to L.A Khan see us yes uh we'll be there
Eric Voss is gonna make an appearance uh
we're gonna do some funny stuff also um
if you're in the LA area it's a fun con
to come to if you're already planning on
being at the con show up in on Sunday I
think we're at Sunday at 11 in uh room
402 something we'll post all this
information sometime soon oh we got a
final Redemption we gotta squeeze in
what are we looking at what is this
that's a cornbread dressing okay hold on
oh You Yank that cup also big question
is back on the Channel with me and
Brandon oh did that just go live today
hey Jessica big question is back oh my
God I don't want this anymore I hate
this sign off all right look away from
him slow fade on this thank you oh my
God Thanksgiving gobble gobble gobble
gobble gobble
[Music]
[Music]